l'évolution du football comme ceux du
rugby va vers une virilité beaucoup plus
accentuée par le passé avec des
physiques si vous regardez par exemple
les joueurs de l'équipe de france de
rugby des années soixante dix avec jean
gachassin qui fait un mètre cinquante
d'eux je ne sais pas comment il pourrait
aujourd'hui jouer au rugby et au
football raymond kopa qui faisait lui
aussi un maître 62 et ce qu'il pourrait
continuer à jouer au football
aujourd'hui mais ce qu'on a vu hier soir
moi je suis un peu plus un peu plus dur
que clive c'est que voilà hier soir il
s'est passé ce qui se passe aujourd hui
en football c'est l'argent la violence
mois pour moi hier soir c'est l'exemple
même c'est la violence avant le stade il
ya des manifestations pendant le match
les pour des raisons inexpliquées mais
de violence à l'égard de quelqu'un qui a
coûté très cher à paris on lui envoie
des canettes de soda ou ddd des chiffons
des cailloux des jus d'orange j'ai vu
des gars là est donc il ya une violence
ces gens qui sont dans la tribune et qui
font ça n'ont rien à voir avec le
football et aujourd'hui vous avez de
plus en plus dans dans le dans le
football
ce type de comportement c'est à dire que
le supporters est devenu aujourd'hui
quelqu'un c'est un cetain souvent un
voyou c'est que c'est parfois un
délinquant il vient pas là pour regarder
d'ailleurs vous verrez vous verrez
souvent que les supporters pendant les
matches il tourne le dos au match